I don't think he saw us ah what the hell
go go go go go go
guys today we're watching such a scary
game then please watch it with a
parental guardian or at least someone
you can hold hands with I don't even
want to look at it it looks so scary how
do I do it how do I keep playing horror
games without getting so scared I don't
know this is a driving horror game never
heard of that have you heard of that I
just hit play and nothing's happening
game of the year what the hell you crash
didn't it know we're still in it
everybody okay yeah all right well let's
let's freaking Judy screams whoa
Oh it's too fast it's too fast oh geez
Rick
[Music]
what the hell where am I going if I even
running away from someone
[Music]
okay okay okay hey all right we're going
we're going we're going we're fine we're
fine we're fine it's just bushes okay
here we go
me I gotta make it Eddie hit Elaine this
goddamn jacksepticeye fanboys they're
coming after me Jesus Christ I'm fine
I'm fine
oh did I hit something
[ __ ] [ __ ] they're coming
[Music]
[ __ ]
I guess I'll die you're never gonna
catch me oh damn I'm the fastest driver
in this in this town wherever I am Q the
deja vu wait wait for it right into the
night - ah boo I have been in their
space before higher than their streets
and I know it's my time to go calling
you I don't even know what I'm running
away from how is this a horror game this
is spooky right
oh wait what's this whoa it looks so
awesome
[Music]
no now leave me alone
dammit faster oh god this is genuinely
scary I'm fine I'm fine I'm just gonna
keep driving face dammit come on okay -
ever Jesus I don't know about this guy's
Weiss is so creepy just keep going
okay this car okay they're fine they're
fine
oh god oh god there's cars everywhere
sorry we go enough road
I don't think he saw us
ah what the hell go go go go go go what
the Frick get off my car you stupid
hillbillies there's nothing wrong with
being a he'll be like oh go go Jesus
Christ Jesus what the heck was that I
don't know about this Burroughs
[Music]
thank God
it's the fortnight fanboys it's the
Marvel fanboys they're finally come
after me I'm sorry I don't like you
Jesus Christ I didn't even do anything
go right oh [ __ ] it was the left turn
Oh God - God I gotta go again oh god I
got agita where does this turn oh my god
I am freaking out where am I going I'm
so lost okay I think we chased them oh
god there's another car don't go the
lake don't go in the lake oh god they're
coming up they're coming up behind me
hey watch where you're driving [ __ ]
hahahaha stupid [ __ ] you don't never
catch me oh we're fine
spike
stop no no get off my car get off my car
you fatty fatty dammit oh my god finally
a horror game that freaked me out a
little bit that's so fun so this is like
an early version of the game it's just a
demo it's obviously gonna build on it I
feel like I said there's a lot of time
some games and then they come out and
it's like it's actually not that great
but I can definitely see some cool
aspects to it like if there was a
passenger next to us adding dialogue
adding some dialogue and dynamic to the
situation some story and why they're
hunting us I don't know or maybe not so
they start hunting you here yeah
[Music]
I'm a really bad driver I don't know if
you guys knew this
[Music]
I'm gonna genuinely try this time
look at this driving boy Swedish racecar
driver number one handbrake initiated
don't hit the radio tower
[Music]
such a unique concept as well I've never
heard of a horror racing game I didn't
know if it would work or not but it's
genuinely scary I'm not sure how long it
will last oh god they're in a rare
winner window I can't speak help me help
me eat there we go yes we're going
offroad baby bad idea I don't know where
the roads go
the lights doesn't really help that much
okay we're going this way Oh God we're
going in the woods
I hate woods they scare me
okay they're right behind us go back sir
no they're coming up satchels get away
from me damn it
keep going keep going keep up
no [ __ ] [ __ ] just u-turn run you'll
never catch me Nevada come here No
I think we got him I think nope
nevermind
I am way too into this come on come on
Felix you can do it we built it we
believe in you Felix thanks guys
remember to smash like on this video and
subscribe right now if you want more
fortnight V bugs
I'm doing a giveaway 500 v bucks
goddammit stop distracting me let's go
this road damn dammit
[ __ ] my art card God okay maybe they
don't see us
they definitely see you
[Music]
some interesting turns
they really start getting more
aggressive after a while
and I just walk in it driving a circle
no get away from man you stupid no
[ __ ]
Oh God I don't know about this DejaVu
come on turn he was supposed to turn
around really awesomely
oh god my cars stuck no my car is stuck
No
stop hitting my car ah damn it death
I like that death I genuinely just want
to play more super interesting
[Music]
oh my god I'm trying so hard I want to
see how far you can make it you know
I think it's to send a looping map
though I'm not sure
[Music]
guys
you just try to pass me without blinking
okay super disrespectful
Oh God where am I going
oh god oh god oh god okay okay okay okay
[Music]
Oh God oh now stop go away bald people
no not like this not like this not like
this weird of all people got I kill ball
people
[Music]
yes
Oh bet you didn't expect that huh
we're back on the offroad oh god the
sliding look at it
oh it's better without the headlights
what oh god don't hit me what did I just
say guys please
you really messed up my car
[Music]
they're coming up on me again come on
we're going fast come up come up I gotta
turn oh damn you can actually crash
sheesh it's like your car is your health
anyway super cool game I really really
love this demo if you're interested in
it check out link in the description
hooray new innovative ideas in the
horror genre always appreciated I think
you guys for watching this video leave
it like if you enjoyed subscribe if you
haven't and ring that Bell and switch it
into gear and that's all for me for now
goodbye everybody goodbye
pretty loud but it's sick so when I'm
taking over you trying to get like here
bro fist to the face can you keep it
with a pace and I'm never gonna switch
how's it going broke gotta get it like
this when you wanna hit the flo rida
like Oakland I'm talking top it never
stop running pretty city and I've never
gotta fly tell me when it go I'm like
whenever I'm done with this pass the mic
there Edgar